all right so Juliana yeah Julia where
are you from originally Los Angeles you
grew up in L.A yeah tell me about how
you grew up yeah both here I went to
Portland Oregon first and I went to the
electrical cocoa Pineville Horus the
forests and Morris trees the Ministries
and it was attacking German area and so
we were like little pet detectives of
Little Tokyo and I found this lady named
Lacey Tuttle in the for the Alameda
apartments and she was a reason why I
was sent to Los Angeles and so she's my
identical twin sister and she came out
here to be a model and so she has a very
well to do but then she disappeared you
remember the Lacey Peterson case Lacy
tunnel was her Merry name and so I came
out here to get her and to take a
pictures of her to send back to Portland
Oregon that she's still alive because
the second she got married her name got
lost in the system and so they blamed me
for her death because women wore boohoo
she's no longer love so I was like I'll
be lazy titles I was like pressing the
button and I was like
[Music]
zero and Co I have your messages for you
I got two drop the gorgeous facts
tell me about your family your parents
my parents they are absolutely White
are you white no what are you I am
Native American you're Native American
yeah but your parents are white yes tell
me about your parents they are negro
official lovers they're like got so
[ __ ] in the ass all black
so many times with black with Michael
Jackson I mean like now Michael
Jackson's Mariah Carey like
so you're describe your childhood to me
sexual sensual and sexual sexual with
who with everybody Ambiance who are you
having sex with
the dollars like you're dropped into my
lap hello you're a kid when I was a kid
I would get tips being a stripper
okay how how old were you when you
started stripping four years old four
yeah the fed's gonna pick me up and
they're like you're way too fine
and uh you've been doing drugs since
when Julia I was in the embryo sac save
stations
okay
what's your drink today meth and weed
hmm what does meth do for you
it makes me wet and sculptures
how much are you smoking
um methamphetamines a day
fifty thousand dollars worth
because I have to include everybody
because I'm the order right how are you
making money today
with this video shoot
no but that's that's just right now is
this oh yeah I prostitute you do yeah
let me escort in fancy restaurants for
food
because you're but you're staying in a
tent around the corner yeah yeah all the
time I am a 10 and give us a 10.
tell me about you've been in Skid Row
how many years seven seven years tell me
about that I was three years
incarcerated in the Mexico Cali sexual
God damn they took me and they had my
arm cut off for three years straight
and they've like put it back on with
like a new bone and then they told me to
County and then they told me that I have
Blaine Blaine blame cancer blame cancer
called bone marrow cancer leukemia and
so I've realized it that my bones coming
the cancer is coming out of my teeth
because I have
etched into my teeth from tweaking
and so I think it's called sculpting and
so I do my own face how does it look you
look beautiful today thank you you
always look different every day I see
you you're different yeah different hair
different makeup
you're gonna buy some real nails like
real girls
holy 37 years old 37. do you have kids
yes I do where are they they're at the
food stamp office
waiting in line
how long they been there six months
got it
I have permission they told me I wanted
to yeah
your family is where
on the highways and freeways FH fvv age
wise
you remember like they're like Highway
for interested
like we're on a close site like come on
now
get tasty with your business be like
like you're not going anywhere like
because I got diagnosed with cancer
yesterday
and I have had had it this whole time
and I'm like I'm a millennium old pretty
healthy for a cancer patient yeah right
like I was in the real Hospital like I
wasn't in um
concrete cemented sale and they gave me
more than enough food to eat and have
let me stare at all of a sudden flying
black guys and he was like I am the
[ __ ] let me take your hand friends from
your hands fine behind you are not
pregnant and I'm like four babies
pregnant and I'm like
how many kids you have four in here
on the way four on the way yeah and then
do September 3rd of 2022.
multiple dads are all one dad
oh you know what yeah they are all my
clones
they're all clones they're multiple like
two identical twins are they twins yeah
got it
like like a two set like two twos I
didn't tell me about the guys who
thinking about when you're working the
street
um I've been over here and I prefer 65
and under
65 and under yeah
because yeah that's how it goes It goes
0-65 and 65 back to zero you just keep
going up and down that's how you live
forever
because your body results treatment
about what's happening so I got it rolls
up picks you up in the car takes you
where
to the parking lot and then they have
[ __ ] me and then they pay me how much
you make 25 a client
cash
using condoms and stuff like that yeah I
had to get two emergency dishes though
because I was having my homies like me
just for feeling so just to pay off a
couple days
like I've been gone this long and they
haven't seen my face so I might as well
get that look in their brains and be
their homegirl
sir are you happy uh no I am Juliana
you're what Juliana heard of shaver no
but are you do you get depressed do you
get angry
um I have schizophrenia you do yeah
would you go to the hospital I found out
I have schizophrenia
unless he was telling me so my maybe my
doctor asked because everyone wanted me
to prescribe him some methamphetamines
or some goddamn weed and I was like
how long does it take you to light
everyone's store have you taken
medications for that before yeah I
dumped a whole bottle of whisper on my
mouth
but you're not taking anything currently
no
crystal meth is your medication yes
how many days will you stay up on that
my whole life do you sleep at all no you
never sleep no
do you have friends here on the street
yes
[Music]
acquaintances or friends
um
friends really that's right like we're
all friends
you like it here yes
do you see yourself living here the rest
of your life or leaving one day yeah I
see myself living here for the rest of
my life living here the rest of it yeah
like they gave me five years to live I
gave a gun and said sweets
and they were nice about it they're like
you can't have a handgun but you're
gonna be higher for five years because
that's how long you have left to live
and then maybe they were like trying to
plan a surprise wedding for me or
something and maybe I was like [ __ ] you
and y'all [ __ ] ass husband [ __ ] he
[ __ ] and sucks me what
there's always time you talk to your
family Wanda Sykes
sides I was in the segmental health
human thing and you know and I got hired
as an actual patient doctor specialist
and so I do understand how many more
minutes are we going to be on film
oh we're almost done okay
when's the last time you talked to your
your parents your family
um this morning
the hospital doctor had drove all the
way to 7th and Stanford right there I
was like ain't you home
and I was like yeah Big Pimpin Daddy
and he was like I'll be right back I
have to go make sure that I still have a
job
and I was like he'll be right here he's
coming in here no matter what I didn't
even asking them if he could come in
there I'm like I have my legs sticking
out the tent because he's gonna find me
any more questions yeah have you had any
like terrible things happen to you while
you're never working down here nope
nothing on Skid Row nothing nothing bad
has happened to you never mad that's
remarkable
it's all plastic surgery
we need plastic surgery drugs you better
cause I'll come kill your ass [ __ ] said
I thought that this was a New York
Undercovers [ __ ] [ __ ] thought a rapper
best people who broke nasty what the
[ __ ] up work they tell me I got an
Exquisite taste in my mouth come [ __ ] me
mouth
the real Nicki Minaj which uh what's the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life nothing [ __ ] with people's
husbands that's a good one
stuff all right John thank you so much
thank you for talking with me you're
welcome be careful out there I will
thank you you're welcome
that's cute